Halloween is like it's like for chicks
and kids you know what the oh man
there's so much stuff about it that's
annoying that it's just like first of
all here's what's got to go and I don't
know why you but I don't know where you
get it CBS save on but who thought this
was bookie this [ __ ] is always somewhere
on Halloween and it just goes all night
dude how are the people that bought that
not losing their [ __ ] minds
watching The Bachelor or whatever in
their living room waiting for [ __ ]
five-year-olds to be trick-or-treating
with their with their single parents
just oh oh oh here's your mounds bar by
the way what are we doing that's the
most annoying thing and it's not even
scary you you walk out your way in the
distance even if you live in the field
with nothing around imagine being that
person's neighbor dude I did a louder
one and just turn I get so many and I
put the [ __ ] airhorn next to it and
it would just be like in there in their
bedroom I'd point it in their bedroom
and then there were they open up the
window and be like what the [ __ ] I'd be
like spooky huh that above all else this
Gaga on Halloween all right that's got
to go
[Music]
[Laughter]